wonder woman is one of dc's most iconic
heroes
and now thanks to the success of her
movie franchise she's as popular as ever
but the amazing amazon's history
is longer and stranger than you might
think here's what even dc fans might not
know about wonder woman wonder woman has
held a wide range of civilian jobs over
the years from military secretary to
professional diplomat but in wonder
woman volume 2 number 73 she takes on
perhaps her most grueling role yet
serving tacos for minimum wage it all
starts when diana returns from outer
space to find the island of themyscira
and
all of its amazons mysteriously missing
left with no money and no purpose the
princess has little choice but to find a
job on her own
with no formal college degree and not
much of an actual resume to speak of
diana ends up at taco wiz serving the
dcu equivalent of fourth meal to long
lines of rude customers
wonder woman can do anything of course
so she's a perfectly capable food
service employee but she's even better
at catching bad guys which is why by the
end of the issue
a private detective has given her a side
job beating up various criminals
soon enough of course the amazons return
and everything goes back to normal
most people think of steve trevor as
wonder woman's faithful long-standing
boyfriend but
things haven't always been easy for the
pair at various times in our history
steve has vanished died or otherwise
been preoccupied
i wish we had more time
what are you saying
it was during one such steveless era
that wonder woman met
buddy baker the d-list hero known as
animal man
wonder woman volume 1 number 267 sees
them meet in costume
with animal man having to remind wonder
woman who he actually is
they subsequently team up to take on an
international crime cartel and diana
realizes buddy isn't the goofball she
first took him for
on the splash page of issue number 268
the heroes are decidedly out of costume
on a beach in france with buddy rubbing
sunscreen on the bikini clad amazon's
back
it wouldn't be long before animal man
got married and had kids while wonder
woman was rebooted by crisis on infinite
earths
but for a brief spell in marseille in
1980 they clearly shared something
special
dc silver age comics are notoriously
weird but wonder woman's might be the
strangest of them all
for these stories writer bob coniger and
artist ross andrew basically went with
whatever popped into their heads
to start with the adult wonder woman
shared her book with her teenage self
wonder girl
and her toddler self wonder tot in fact
the trio often appeared in stories
together with only the vagus
explanations of how that was actually
possible
then there's the glop who showed up in
wonder woman volume 1
number 151 he's described as a teenager
himself although it was kind of hard to
tell considering he was just a giant
pile of slime from outer space
but when he absorbed a bunch of rock and
roll records he started singing his own
kooky songs mostly about how much he
wanted to date wonder girl
it was a pretty unsettling proposition
fortunately the whole thing turned out
to be a dream
but hey that's the 60s for you of course
this being comics that didn't stop
the glop from making further appearances
over the years because why would you
waste a character like this
wonder woman volume 1 number 170
features another silver age adventure by
conoger and andrew
and yes that means another unsettling
suitor from outer space
this time it's an intelligent alien
gorilla who wants to make wonder woman
his queen
and uses a ray gun to change her into a
gorilla as well
diana talks her way back into humanity
by explaining that as a human she's an
amazon of mythical beauty and grace but
as a gorilla she's just like any other
female gorilla then she tricks the space
gorilla into using the gorilla ray on
himself
making him a human man that enables her
to use her magic
lasso which doesn't work on animals to
compel him to leave earth in his flying
saucer
and so ends another day in dc's silver
age
in all-star comics number 13 nazi agents
capture the justice society of america
placing each of them inside a small
rocket and launching them into space
each hero ends up on a different planet
in the solar system and naturally
all of those planets are home to
intelligent life starman assists the
sentient robots of jupiter
johnny thunder helps out the giant
spiders of mercury and so on and so on
wonder woman's chapter was crafted by
her creators william marston and harry
peter so naturally the amazing amazon
finds herself on venus the matriarchal
planet of love
however just before wonder woman arrived
venus was invaded by hulking patriarchal
meteor men
none of the venusians are prepared to
fight them but wonder woman takes them
down easily and is hailed as the savior
of venus
queen desera of venus promises to return
the favor whenever she can
and goes on to become a recurring
character in wonder woman's own line of
comics
steve trevor is an okay guy but it's
kind of a shame he never really got to
be a superhero himself
except of course that he totally did in
wonder woman vol
1 number 174 steve becomes the patriot
a superhero of exceptional strength and
speed whose all-american costume
immediately brings to mind a certain
other hero named steve
it's a good thing the patriot is here to
save the day because by some strange
coincidence wonder woman loses her
powers at the same time
of course it's not a coincidence at all
this is all a plot by the angle man
wonder woman's greatest silver age
nemesis
his latest angle sorry is to get wonder
woman to retire by simultaneously
stealing her powers and making her feel
like steve has replaced her wonder woman
doesn't give up so easily however and
soon enough everything is back in its
right place
even steve himself comes to realize that
he's far more comfortable in his army
uniform than spandex and buccaneer boots
[Music]
walter hills the warriors is a cult
classic now but in 1979 it was a fresh
and daring pop culture innovation
and anyone who had seen it would
recognize the shirtless vest clad trio
on the cover of wonder woman vol 1
number 262.
it's obvious that writer jerry conway
and artist jose delbo
had just seen the movie and couldn't
resist referencing it in their comic the
warriors only appear for a few pages of
the actual story however in which wonder
woman teaches them
a rough lesson about how crime doesn't
pay it's hard to say if conway was a fan
of the movie or had a problem with its
glamorization of street gangs and was
simply trying to make a point
either way it's fun to see a bronze age
comic deal so directly with what was
going on in other media at the time
it seems like every super strong hero
ends up in an alien gladiatorial arena
sooner or later
and it happened to both wonder woman and
supergirl in wonder woman vol
1 number 177 in this comic an armored
alien conqueror named claimos has
captured powerful women from
all over the cosmos in his hunt for a
bride but none are as powerful as the
amazon and the kryptonian he found on
earth
obviously they don't want to fight each
other but klamos is ready to destroy the
earth if they refuse
so the duo performs some pretty
impressive wrestling moves with each
other but
it's all a setup for supergirl to hurl
wonder woman into the royal box where
klamos and his ever ever-present
chamberlain
grok are watching diana hurls grok back
into the arena where kara reveals that
he uses a wrist computer to control
clamos who's nothing more than a robot
a whole galaxy is freed from tyranny and
the two heroes return home to earth
wonder woman vol 1 number 185 remains a
particularly infamous story
one that hails from the period in which
wonder woman had given up her costume
and powers to become a stylish
globetrotting adventurer
she also owned her own fashion boutique
in new york city cause why not returning
to her shop one evening diana finds a
teenage girl named kathy
hiding in fear from a group she refers
to only as
them kathy turns out to be on the run
from a trio of lesbian stereotypes who
want to keep her as a collared slave of
course words like gay or lesbian are
never used in the comic but
it's not hard to read between the lines
obviously it's pretty gross how this
comic portrays queer people
naturally wonder woman makes short work
of them and thankfully the next time
gay characters appear in wonder woman
comics it's under far more positive
circumstances
by 1973 wonder woman was back in costume
and had reunited with the amazons
meanwhile comics started to take more
interest in black characters
although it's worth pointing out that
they were often the somewhat clumsy
creations of white writers
so it can't have been surprising in
wonder woman number 204 when a heavily
armored warrior woman removes her helmet
to reveal herself as
black declaring herself to be nubia
wonder woman of the floating island
nubia was meant as a sort of opposite to
diana her breastplate was adorned with a
lion instead of an eagle
instead of a magic lasso she had a magic
sword and instead of the princess of an
island of women she ruled an island that
was otherwise
all men queen hippolyta seems to
recognize nubia
and soon enough reveals the truth that
diana wasn't the only daughter she'd
sculpted from clay
she had formed another child of darker
clay nubia who was stolen as an
infant by the evil god of war mars mars
had raised nubia to be his weapon
against the peace-loving amazons but
diana frees her
from his influence and the two become
friends nubia in turn spreads the
message of peace to the men of her
island and everything turns out alright
nubia was dc comics first black heroine
and she's reappeared numerous times over
the years she's even getting her own
graphic novel in 2021 from writer l l
mckinney and artist robin smith
you might remember how princess diana
lost the wonder woman title in the 90s
to an amazon named artemis
it was after superman died and batman
got his back broken
so being replaced was kind of in vogue
for dc heroes
but it wasn't the first time a
red-haired amazon had stolen wonder
woman's job
wonder woman vol 1 number 250 and 251
told a very similar story in which an
upstart amazon named orana calls for a
new tournament on paradise island and
wins the right to become wonder woman
although she's supposed to stay with the
other amazons diana sneaks back to new
york as diana prince and keeps an eye on
orana who has a hard time getting anyone
to accept that she's a valid wonder
woman
she's also not particularly good at the
job and ultimately sacrifices her life
in battle against the villain named
warhead
diana returns orana's body to paradise
island and solemnly resumes the mantle
of wonder woman
almost two decades later the artemis
narrative was essentially a retelling of
the orana story only longer
and with a few more twists and turns
along the way that's the thing about
long-running superhero comics though
even the strangest things often happen
more than once because the story cycle
just keeps on turning
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one